l'immigration de masse a dépassé nos
capacités d'intégration
la france connaît le record de titres de
séjour délivrés le record de nouvelles
demandes d'asile plus de 123 me l'an
dernier ce qui fait de nous un des pays
les plus importants en europe alors
qu'elle baisse de 10% en europe
le record des mineurs non accompagnés
nous sommes aujourd'hui à mi mandat et
nous ne savons toujours pas sur quoi
votre grande réforme des retraites doit
déboucher cette question en flammes
nombre de nos concitoyens dans les
inquiétudes des tout prochains retraités
sont grandes
nul ne sait s'il ne devra pas payer
demain plus de cotisations sans
percevoir ensuite une retraite plus
élevée
nul ne sait si l'alcool de l'âme
retraite par points envisagés n'est pas
dans votre esprit une simple supercherie
qui défavorisera nous retraités
nul ne sait si l'âge de départ en
retraite ne sera pas une nouvelle source
d'inégalité
nous avons été nombreux à être
particulièrement choqués par la légèreté
avec laquelle vous avez considéré les
agressions criminelles de
chanteloup-les-vignes samedi soir quand
des policiers sont caillassés et
violemment attaqué au mortier d'artifice
quand un bâtiment culturel de la ville
est incendiée il ne s'agit pas d'
agissements d'une petite bande
d'imbéciles et d'irresponsables comme
vous les avez qualifié mais d'actes
criminels qu'il faut réprimer avec
fermeté connaissez-vous
chanteloup-les-vignes monsieur le
premier ministre c'est une ville de
10000 habitants à l'ouest de paris dans
les yvelines qui est aujourd'hui
meurtrie par les affrontements de samedi
entre des criminels et des policiers ces
affrontements ente entraîné l'incendié
d'un équipement collectif champions est
une ville française comme menthe béziers
où brest et qui aujourd'hui pansent
leurs plaies et se battent au quotidien
pour reconquérir mètre carré par mètre
carré
chaque morceau de son leur territoire
républicain que des criminels souhaite
voir disloqué 13% des élèves en
situation de handicap ne sont pas
scolarisés de façon régulière avec un
véritable accompagnement de nombreux
enfants ne bénéficient pas de
l'accompagnement adaptés à leurs besoins
les familles vivent cette situation
comme un abandon de l'institution dont
le rôle est de protéger et d'accompagner
en les accompagnant d
élèves en situation de handicap sont
encore trop peu nombreux mal rémunérés
voix rémunérés avec du retard
ce n'est pas acceptable comment peut-on
se satisfaire de cette situation sur la
réforme du baccalauréat
cette réforme que vous mettez en place
modifie le parcours de formation et les
modalités de l'examen du baccalauréat
dire que cette réforme ne passe pas est
un euphémisme
beaucoup craignent l'instauration d'un
bac locale inégalitaire entre les
candidats et les établissements manquent
de clarté d'information mais aussi
d'anticipations
[Musique]